step up star Alyson Stoner comes out as  queer in a candid new essay written for  Teen Vogue the 24 year old performer  opens up about the years she spent in  therapy coming to terms with her  sexuality telling readers she sought  help from religious leaders and Friends  to be quote anything that besides gay  and reveals a girl changed everything  she knew about herself as a woman and a  human being explaining in its purest  sense I felt awakened more compassionate  and like my truest self now that she's  accepted herself and who she loves the  dancer is asking the world to do the  same quote I'm asking you to accept me  as I accept myself I Allison am  attracted to men women and people who  identify in other ways I can love people  of every gender identity and expression  it is the soul that captivates me  [Music]  [Applause]